Look, there's a rumor going around that I really love seafood. First of all, that's false. I like it. I don't love it, but I like sushi more, but I think what the real rumor was going around that I like women, which is totally not true. Welcome to smart less. Hi. When did you get home?
Well, I just got back today. Oh my gosh. Yeah, it's really exciting. I had a great time. Thanks for asking. Well, so you still do it old school. You dress up nice for plane flights. Is that right?
Listener, Will's got a nice collar and a v-neck on. I do, actually. You kind of dress up every day anyway. Oh, yeah. Were you flying first class on Panayam or something? Or something, but let me just say. Oh, is that right, eh? Well, you know.
Good for you. I mean. You know, you don't need to dress up for that one. They wait for you. I know, and I do. And you know, I think that you can't coach people up all the time, but you can just model it for them. So I'm just like, I'm trying to set this standard.
I'm like, I'm not going to tell everybody else how to do it. And I'm just going to do it. I'm just lead by example. And I feel like, yeah, it should look nice. I don't see why not. I was, I was in Atlanta, you know, I had a great time. Thanks for asking though. I really did.
I had a really nice time and it was with all my friends. What were you doing down there? Let's plug some of your stuff. Well, you know, I was working on the, we were making more of these, this Lego program that I like to make. Sure. Most of Lego program. And I also, you do?
Sure. Yeah. And I produce it as well. And we have a really fun time down there. Do you drive a GMC when you're down there or eating any Reese's Candies? I was actually, you know, don't, don't tell them I was in a Chevy. Wait, what? That's okay.
It's within the GM family. It's okay. Is it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And cause GMC and Chevy are both divisions of GM.
That's enough. That's enough. And I had great meals made by my friend, Brandy. If you're down in Atlanta and you need to. So you're in the Camaro. You're in the Camaro. Was it a five-speed Camaro? It was a suburban.
Oh, so you weren't driving. You were riding in a Chevy. No, I drove it every day. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I like to, you know, I like to get behind the wheel of a big truck. You had a pull hitch on that suburban, did you? You know, part of the problem is sometimes.
Did you wait? Did you, wait, did you, did you, are you done, done? You don't have to go back. You're done. I'm done. I don't have to go back. I remember I came back before. Yeah.
I'm really excited. I'm really excited to be here with you guys. I literally got here this afternoon. I'm so happy. Jason. Somebody loves Los Angeles. And Shawnee, you're back in Los Angeles too. I am too.
We're all back. We're going to see each other Sunday, maybe. Sunday night where we're doing Sunday Funday. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Did you not even know about this? I just got home.
I'm sure Amanda's got a full menu of plans that you've created with her. We did. Will and I share a wife. Let's see. Yeah, it's true. I love that I know before you and Shawn does too. It's so good. Yeah.
Sunday's going to be fun. I can't wait. I'm really excited to see all y'all. Tracy might come. Is that true? Is that right? Yeah. Listen.
No way. Listen, this is significant. Do we have to explain stuff at dinner? Which food is it? What? Well, we're the fork. This is a fork. Yeah.
Jason was making fun of my name before you got on. Will and he was making fun of the menu. They've been misspelling it all these years. It's S-H-A-W-N. And Hayes, everybody knows is H-A-I-S-E. No, but anyways, I had. That's why you're so bad at Quirtle. Quirtle.
And Quirtle is bigger than Quirtle. No, Shawn. Shawn, we went from Quirtle to Quirtle. I can't do it. I try it. So now we're on a chain with Sam Jones and with Mr. Yes, our friend Matt. Our friend Matt Damon.
And Jason struggled with Quirtle. But you know what? We've been gentle on him. We have to Quirtle. Matt and I tied against today. So now we're going, we're now decided that tie break. You have to go to Octortle. Whatever it's called.
It's eight. Octortle. It's so stupid. And it gets real chippy in that chain, doesn't it? You've had some good runs, but it gets chippy in there. Will's gifted. Will's, uh, he's surprisingly good at some things you wouldn't think he's good at.
And then shockingly bad at stuff you think he just kind of breathes through, you know, like, uh, driving. I really bad at driving. Sometimes walking. Boy, you put a stick of gum in his mouth and ask him to walk down the street. It's, uh, it's something. No.
Did you guys, yeah, go ahead. Sean, you were. No, you go. I was going to get to our guest or you were going to get to the guest. Well, they've been waiting for good 45 minutes. No, they haven't. We had a five o'clock record time.
Will. No, we had. Oh my God. No, he's made me panic. I know the way he does it. By the way, Sean. Yes. Speaking of dressing up, you're wearing a nice shirt today.
I am. You want to know why I swear to God? Because first of all, let me just say for our listener, no baseball cap and no t-shirt that says like Bob's beer. Yeah. And it's a lavender gingham button up. So clearly what time did mask get out today? Yeah.
Sean, what happened? And by the way, stand up because I want to see the dockers too. Yeah, no, they are dockers tucked into some pleated khakis. They are dock. They are dock. Cargo pants.
Cargo pants. What happened? Did you unlock a time capsule for 1998? Does it have a loop for the hammer? I was just playing Uncharted. No, I swear to God, I did not make this up. I woke up today and I saw my sweats and my shorts. I was like, gosh, I wear that every day.
Even to parties. Yeah, even to parties. And then I was like, you know what? Poor Scotty never sees me dressed as a human being. So for Scotty today, I dressed in a nice shirt and just regular pants. Just to kick around the house and eat your tuna fish sandwiches?
Yeah, totally. By the way, not even kidding, had a tuna fish sandwich today and a little bit of spaghetti. Of course, not kidding. There's nothing kidding about that. Yeah, this is very serious business, dude. Anyway, thank you for noticing. You look great.
So that's just your kick around outfit today. That's my kick around outfit today. I mean, that's stuff to do, but yeah. And is this the same haircut from 12 days ago from Scandal? Oh, I thought you were going to say. Yes, it is. Oh, it is.
It's getting long, right? It's getting a little long on top there. I'm going to have a question. Can we come in for your next sesh? What's his name? What's his name again? It's Skevo. Skevo.
I'm not Skevo if you're listening. I'm not laughing at you. I just appreciate the salon name. I know. Wait a minute, Jason. It's the same salon you go to. I just go to a different guy. Yeah, but my guy's name is Chris.
You know, like, it's Skevo. You can't do anything but cut hair with a name like Skevo. Jason, let me ask you. Did Chris break both his hands? No, no, no. No, no. No, no.
No, no. No, no. Did he break both his hands? What's going on? Is he not? Listen, I've got some real growth going on. I actually kind of like the long hair. It's not great.
It's not great. We'll let our guest weigh in on this, but I need the hat, at least. All right, let's get to it. Let's go. Let's go with this guest. Here we go. Our guest today is a pretty major guest.
I think you'll be impressed. I'm so excited he agreed to do this. The man is hilarious. And just when we thought he couldn't get more successful and at the top of his game, his career became a marvel. And everything shifted for this handsome, funny man, which is usually an oxymoron. He's so clearly one of the most sought after actors
in Hollywood starring in Blockbuster. But most important above all, he's also one of the kindest, most humblest men I've ever known. So we really aren't worthy. But regardless, welcome to smartless Christopher Pratt. Chris Pratt. I knew I had it with the Chris. Damn it.
Are you serious? I know. Oh boy. Now, Sean, you and I are going to have to just take a seat and let these two. I know. Because they love each other so much. They went to space camp.
But we were just talking about him coming on this show. And that's why I know. Well, Will, why didn't you invite him? I mean, Chris. I know. Why didn't you invite me? What's wrong with you, Will? Oh my god.
This is such a, and I just checked in with Michael recently and I was like, what's going on with Pratt? He's like, it's going to happen. Let me just get back. I'm like, OK. This is like, OK. Sean and I are just fascinated. I'm happy you're here.
I'm happy I'm here. Hi, Chris. I'm like, hi, guys. I love that man we're talking to right now named Chris Pratt. And I don't know if you guys know, but I'm really close. I've known his wife, Catherine, for decades, literally decades since she was a child. So I feel like she's my little sister.
Great story. Chris, welcome to the show. Look, you've got a collar on too. I know. Yeah, why do you look so nice, Chris? We are wrapping up. This is what I was, you know, wearing today. Eating tuna for sandwiches?
For work. I was doing some Pratt stuff, so they had me dressed up. If you've ever seen me dress nice, it's because I did something for work. Now, is this a junket? Is this a junket outfit or a photography session outfit or a talk show? This?
What did we do today? I did a talk show. I did the Kelly Clarkson show. Sure. All right. And how was that? It was great. We did it with the whole cast of, well,
a bunch of the cast members from Jurassic World. Jurassic World Dominion, you mean? Not from Jurassic World. What is that? Is that some sort of? That was good. That was really good. That was a good save by my brother.
Wait a minute. Let me tell you something. I watched that movie and I was blown away. That is an incredible ride. It's so great. I'm so glad you said away. I'm so glad you said away. It was blown period.
I was like, where did you see the movie? Why do you think I dressed up for that? I saw all of it. My friend, however, missed a large chunk of it. Universal is loving this. Universal is so happy. It's the kind of family content. No.
It is so good, Chris. I hope you're proud of it because it's fucking amazing. It's so great. I am. It is really good. It's a great progression from the previous movie. It just keeps getting better and better. What's nice is the whole cast from Jurassic Park is back in this movie.
Yes. To see you guys together was so cool. This is Sam Neal and Jeff Goldblum and Laura Dern. Laura Dern, Beaty Wong. Were all the dinosaurs available? Many of the same dinosaurs came back. Could make their deals. It's not just actors.
Unbelievable. I want to ask you something, Chris. When someone is as massively successful as you and you know, you know. Last question, Sean. Oh, I'm sorry. No, that's fine. Then you got to go. Last question already.
Fuck. No, no, sorry. Go ahead. Sorry. I have to speed things up. No, when someone is as hugely successful as you and you know, you know every time you open a movie that it's going to be seen by the world. Do you ever go, damn, all my hard work paid off?
Are you aware enough to embrace your own success? Can you enjoy it? Are you like push it away? Deflect. Oh, man. You can't win answering this question. This is what Sean does. Why not?
He puts all the praise and then he drops a bomb on you that you can't win. And then he says, Chris, please walk into Douche Town. I want you to walk into Douche Town. Join me. I want you to say something about yourself that makes everyone think that you're a complete asshole. No, no, no. Sean, why don't you ask him how many times a day he Googles himself, okay?
I'll answer that for myself. No, no, I was asking because it's like a healthy thing to say. Yes, I'm proud of what I've done. Like it's okay to say that. I think it's so amazing that you're such a gigantic global star now and from where you came that you should feel proud because you have worked so hard. So I'll say it for you. Amen.
There it is. I will second that. That's so nice. Yeah. I mean, look, I feel, I feel like definitely like blessed and grateful. I've got an awesome manager who forces me to say no to things that I would absolutely say yes to if it weren't for my manager. So like I have, it's like the result of really great discernment on my team.
It's definitely a team effort. And I've been lucky enough to hitch my, you know, wagon to these titles that were really, really special and big titles with Marvel and with Jurassic World. So it's like, you know, and not to deflect or anything like that. Like definitely proud of my contribution to them, but these are, these were like juggernauts that I was lucky enough to jump on. And so like it's been an awesome. But you would definitely not, hold on, Will, you would definitely not shy away from something
that was fully dependent on you though, right? Without, without any sort of like, you'd go off, do some original one act in an equity waiver theater. Would you not? We got him. Oh, immediately. Yeah. Yeah.
It would have to be the right. It would have to be the right. The right time of the year. Why? What do you have? And go for Will. I was just noticing that you all, you were saying you were really grateful and blessed and you kind of at first had your glass and I was like, that's a great, you created
a nice word, which is grateful and I feel really blessed. Oh, that's right. It's a mashup. Or personally, I'm blade. I am. Glast would be really good. Glast would save you a lot of time. You know what I mean?
It's like if you didn't have to say grateful and blessed for all the times you're forced to say that. Think of all the time. I first fell in love with Chris Pratt when he was nice enough to do our little chat and giggle for, I believe it was Denny's one. Will and I were running a digital ad agency for about three seconds. And we came up with some, what? Do you remember that?
I do. With Kekner? With Kekner. Yeah. Were you on Parks and Recs at the time or before? I think you were, weren't you? I think it was Parks and Rec. Yeah.
I think it might have been Parks and Rec or around then. Yeah. Yeah, it was Parks and Rec. And what happened was, first of all, I fell in love with Pratt because when he first did that first season of Parks and Rec and I started to watch the cuts of the show and Amy will back me up on this, I was watching the episodes and I was like, who the fuck is this guy? This guy is fucking hilarious. He played Andy.
He was Rashida's boyfriend. He had a broken leg. He was a good for nothing dude. Like stuck at home making her do shit for him. And she was like, oh God, dating this loser guy. And he was so funny, so effortlessly funny. I was like, this guy's fucking it. And Will doesn't give it up for a lot, Chris.
That's high praise. I don't know. Pratt, well, he knows. He knows how much I love him. And then Pratt did one of the funniest things I've ever seen. I saw him on Conan years ago, early on. You probably don't remember this. And you go, you get at one point, you're talking to Conan, and then you stood up and you start
to take your jacket off. And Conan goes, what are you doing? You go, I'm hot. And nobody ever does that on a talk show. I thought you were going to say that he just collapsed on the ground. And then he said, what are you doing? And he said, I just did a Pratt fall. That would have killed.
For me, it was funnier that he just took his jacket off. And then he was relaxed. And I thought, this son of a gun. It's a different beat. Chris, why are you so relaxed on those shows? Why are you so relaxed? What's the name of the pharmaceutical? Do you shoot at the back of your knee?
Or is it just a tablet? I heard someone today was talking about that they were like, I asked someone, I said, do you get nervous before you go through this? And someone had mentioned, oh, I'd take a, what did they say? There was some pill that they took. There's like, I take it this. It was like a, I don't know if there was like a name. Beta blocker, like a beta blocker.
A blocker, a blocker. A beta blocker, yeah. A beta blocker. Look at the acting skills on Chris. He just, he seems like he's never heard of these things, you know? Like what's the- A beta blocker? Yeah dude, Chris, by the way, that's the real thing is I take a beta blocker every time around
Bateman and then I can't hear him. It blocks about. It blocks out all the betas. A beta blocker. Yeah, that's a machine. He's calling me a beta and it's the beta thing, Sean. It's even more hard. But like, I don't feel, like I've never had, I don't know, I think I have natural beta
blockers in my head. What do you get, what do you get nervous about? Golf. I know you're a great golfer, so probably not that. Golf. No. I'm a complete head case in golf. Really?
Really? Yeah. It messes my whole game up. I can't just go and like, you know, some of those guys are like, ah. Because the thing is, I'm not as good at golf as I am at like going on a talk show. You know what I mean? If I was as good at golf as I was, like just sitting down at a talk show and shooting the shit and making me-
Well, what kind of golfer are you? Mid-80s, mid-90s? I'm like a 14. Yeah, there you go. That's great. It's not great. It should be better. For the amount of time and effort I put in, I can't tell you how many times I'll be on
the golf course and I'll legit go, you know what, fucking fuck this fucking game. Right. I quit. What am I doing? What am I doing? I'm spending all my time doing this and this is only how good I am? Why? I could have written a book.
I could have gotten a degree. I could have done anything with my fucking life. And then I get a good shot. I'm like, yeah, baby. Yeah, baby. That is back. So that's like the emotional roller coaster. I know.
Chris, I'll tell you what though. One time, a couple of months ago, we were playing golf. Jason and I were playing golf and we saw a couple of guys at the place we were playing. It was before the LA, the, the Genesis. Yeah. And we saw a couple of pros playing and I was having a bad day. And these guys, we saw a DJ and a couple of guys having a practice round and Jason points up to them on, they're on a different hole.
And he, and he, and he says to me, just to give me a perspective, cause I was in a bad place and he goes, they can't do what you do. And I went, oh yeah. You're a professional at something completely different. Yeah. You're an amateur at what you're a pro at. Yeah. And I was like, okay.
And it, and it put it in perspective and Jason hats off. It made the rest of my day quite pleasant. So thank you. That's nice. You helped my experience. I love you. When you give back, when I give to you and you give back to me, I love that. That's pretty cool.
Jason usually tells me, I can't do anything. You're an amateur at everything. Now get in the car. And now a word from our sponsor. And now back to the show. Let me ask you this. I've never, I've never known. I know that before parks and rec, you were doing a sort of a show.
You were doing a much more serious show. Right. What was the name of the show you did before for a couple years? I did a TV show. Well, it was like a teen drama. It was called everwood. It was on the WB. Everwood.
So not a comment. One of the, one of my early claims of fame was that Sean Hayes made an everwood joke on willing grace. And we all thought that we made it. He was like, I'm going to stay at home and have everwood with my date or something like that. Like that was the joke was like everwood, like an everlasting boner. I think you had an everwood watching, watching Jurassic the other day.
Right. Wow. Do you, I love the sound effects. So Chris, but that show, not a comedy. Right. What was the, what was the first, I mean, God, I, I didn't know you've gone on. You've done lots of different stuff and you've done action. You've done stuff that's more intense or whatever.
But for me, I feel like you've got such a comedic heart, which I love. It's so rare. Like in my little intro, I really mean that. Like good looks with comedy is so rare. Yeah. Oh guys. Thank you. Fun.
Who are you talking to? I can't tell who you're looking at on this show. I'm sorry. I can't see. I was looking in a mirror. Just off the side. I have a mirror set up in my, you forgot you were doing the show. Now Chris, I know you're too humble to really address this question, but if you were to
concede that you are affable and good looking and approachable and an everyman, would you blame that on your dad, your mom? You got a brother who's like that. Like where, where, where'd you, where'd you get it from? Where'd you get it? I think, you know, growing up with my family, just we were talking about this will when it lands together, the love language is just legit burns, you know, cutting each other up, like, like insult love.
You know what I mean? Where you kind of just say gloves are off. I will absolutely allow you to say anything you want to try to cut me down and I'll appreciate what you do for its humor. And you know, like no one gets their feelings hurt and always, always has their feelings hurt a little bit. Yeah. Exactly.
It thickens your skin. Yeah. You're just not allowed to take yourself too seriously. I think that's it. I think it's like, you know, appreciating comedy and just, just getting the piss taken out of you. Right. But for, but for people who don't know, and I think Will was kind of hinting at this
is like, I'm sure you're sick of talking about this, but you worked at Bubba Gump Shrimp and Maui while you were homeless, which is like blows my mind. Wait, that's news to me. Me too. How did you end up in Maui? Well, I, after I, I didn't go to college and I, you know, I did like a semester of community college that I was like paying for myself and just hated it. Shrimp?
No, no, no, this is before the shrimp. Because I, you know, I graduated, I was young, I was 17 when I graduated. I had done sports through school. So I never did any plays. However, I was always MCing, writing and kind of producing our assemblies at school following my brother's footsteps. He had done the same thing. So I really loved the showmanship and doing these song and dance numbers and like comedy
sketches in front of the school and stuff, really kind of scoring with that stuff. I did stand-up comedy right after high school. I did a community play right after high school. Started doing several plays at this local theater. So I knew I had the bug that I wanted to be a performer, but it seemed outrageous to me. I became a door-to-door salesman and I did that job for, yeah, I did that job for about, I mean, probably a little over a year, maybe a year and a half. How old?
I was, you know, from the time I was 18 to about almost 20. What were you selling? I was selling these coupons. So like businesses in the service industry, such as a Minakie or a Midas or maybe like even a salon would put together this like package of like, you know, bring your car in, you'd get oil changes. Four oil changes for $20 was the deal, but really we would sell it to the person and they would take their car and get free oil changes.
But really the mechanic would try to like upsell them on a break job or something like that. So it was like this is a coupon kind of a thing. It's criminal in nature basically, right? No, you just sold me. It was a little bit of a pyramid scheme. Good. It was kind of, yeah. It was like these multi-level marketing things were like, you know, I was a, first of all,
zero critical thinking skills were ever taught to anyone in my household. My mom was a checker at Safeway for 29 years. She'd literally believe anything anyone told her through her life. She's still that way. We bless her hard. And so I answered an ad in the paper for this door-to-door sales thing that said, do you like rock and roll music? Do you want to make money?
And I was like, oh my God, I think this might be it. I think this might be it. Well, I've posted those things. And it was that. And so for a year I did this door-to-door sales job. And after I opened my own office in Colorado, like climbed to the top. I've got all the sales awards and won a free trip to Jamaica. I did very well at this job.
But then I got totally burnt out and learned that my management skills were terrible. I was just really good at selling shit. And so when I tried to open my own office and I put the same ad in the paper, it turned out only ding-dongs would answer. And the guy's like, I like that. I was like, cool, let's go, let's get excited. And they're like, I don't really, I forgot my shoes or whatever. Why is there just like scraping the bottom of the unemployment barrel?
Wait, what were the two questions? Holy shit. Do you like rock and roll and like to have fun or like to make money? Do you want, do you like rock and roll music? Do you want to make money? I mean, that's going to solicit some real questionable. Wait, so why did hindsight? It wasn't the best ad, but I was the guy who answered that ad.
So I thought that's effective. There's probably a bunch of like... It netted me. Yeah. Scooped you right up. It reminds me of that line. Remember in Idiocracy when the guy says to Dax, I like money? He goes, I like money too.
I mean, what it really does is the true brilliance in it is it filters out people who are too critical of critical thinkers, you know what I mean? Like if you're dumb enough to answer that ad, then you might get pulled into this multi-level marketing thing. There's a stroke of evil genius to it. So Colorado didn't work out. How do you get to Maui? That's what, yeah.
So I had to give that backstory to say that my mom had to fly me home from Colorado. I had like a $1,500 cell phone bill debt. Really? And I just went back to my hometown where I had like... This is Maui. You grew up in Maui? No, no, no. I grew up in a town called Lake Steves in Washington State,
but a good friend of mine since high school had been living in Maui. And he saw me and he was like, dude, what happened? I heard you were like a big, big, big sales in a sales company or something. And he said, listen, man, I'm going to buy you a one-way ticket to Maui. I've been living there since high school. It's awesome. We sleep on the beach. It's super fun.
If you like to make money, you like to fly to Maui. And so he paid for my ticket out there and then I just basically moved there. And so I had no money, but I showed up and hung out with a bunch of friends and got a job at Bubblegum Shrimp Company and lived on the beach in this sort of... People say homeless and you kind of like living in LA. There's homeless people everywhere. It's like destitute people. Just a bunch of kids living camping on the beach for a year.
Because you could. Yeah. And then where did the acting bug and the trip to LA come from? Well, I always had that acting bug from having performed in school and having done plays. And I was doing stand-up comedy while I was doing the sales thing because that office was in Seattle. So I was performing at some open mic nights and things like that. Entry like I did a college tour thing at the University of Washington and stuff doing stand-up comedy. So I had the bug and I just, I waited on a director and the director saw me and was like,
Hey, you're cute. You act. And I was like, Yeah, I totally act. You should put me in a movie. And the audition came and I auditioned for a movie. And the movie was, you know, I got paid 700 bucks. It was shot over 10 days. It was like this when he sagged, signatory type of films.
And I remember auditioning and I worked so hard on this material. And I just remember halfway through the director said, you know what, you're pretty good. We're going to use you. And I'm like, wow, I think I'm going to get, I got this part that's great. I said, where do you, where does it film? Like, is it, is it like on this side of the island? Does the other side? I said, Oh, no, a film's in LA.
And in my mind, I'm like, well, I've got maybe 60 bucks to my name. I can't go to LA. Plus you've got barbecue shrimp, grilled shrimp, mustard shrimp, boiled shrimp, fried shrimp, fried shrimp, mustard shrimp, barbecue shrimp, fried shrimp, fried salad shrimp. So dumb. But you met this Hollywood Titan at a table for one at Bubba Shrimp. Shrimp. Yes.
This. Okay. Yeah. The director and her producing partner were getting ready to shoot this movie. And then it was like a, you know, I auditioned and then I said, I can't, I can't go to LA. I don't have any, I don't have any money to get to LA. And she said, sweetie will fly you there. And that was it.
And I never, never went back. No way. Had you ever been to LA? Never. Oh, well, only time I'd been to LA was on a door to door sales road trip where I came down to sell some stuff because they had an LA office. So I, they, they had sent me down to sell in some areas. Like I sold an oxnard and I was on like up and down Santa Monica Boulevard and West Hollywood
and stuff. But that's so interesting because I picture like you in Maui or anybody who wants to be an actor. I think the last place to find work is Maui. It is. It's so crazy. Yeah. It wasn't one of these things that I was really looking for it.
It was, I was just, I was just having a good time with my friends and enjoying my life and had that opportunity not presented like literally shaking the tree and knocked me out of the tree and grabbed me by the hair and dragged me to LA. I don't know that I've ever, I ever would have had an opportunity to pursue what was a dream of. Yeah. It's a while. You're going door to door.
You're talking about like Santa Monica Boulevard, just going door to door. Yeah. You're talking about business. We would always sell the people. Oh, business to business. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So B2B, but are you? It's not B2B, Will. Jason, you're not in the thing. You're not in the game with us. Sorry. In the game. We're on B2B. I'm going to correct you on the B2B stuff.
No, you're not in the game. That's not a phrase. No, we're going. Do you think we have time to go business to business? No. We're going B2B. What time? No.
We're going to B2B every second. So you're going to B2B. I'm with you. But you must have crazy. Crazy encounters, were you going cold calling? Yeah, I had crazy encounters. You did? It was terrible.
I mean, yeah, terrible. It's funny now to hear actors talk about rejection, you know? They're like, dude, it's so hard. I'm like, mother, you were invited to the place where you got rejected. I'm sneaking through people's yards and trying to climb in their windows just to talk to someone who I'm walking right past a no soliciting sign to solicit. Right. Shotgun blast could come right through that door.
Well, I had people try to stick their dogs on me. I had like, I had my crew, people that I hired on my crew, you know, the elite sales force that answered them, the Ding Dong ad. The other folks that love the rock and roll and money. They would go in and rob places. Wait, really? Yeah. I had hired up in Seattle on my crew.
I hired a guy who was like a violent felon, a convicted two time violent felon on house arrest. And we were like, hey, listen, this guy's great. We really like him. They're like, he needs to be under supervision all the time. He absolutely will be like, hey, buddy, this is your street. We'll pick him at five. No way.
That's not. No way. Yeah, for real. And that guy, Audie, his name is Audie. He was very sweet. He was actually an amazing guy and he was a really special guy. Like, it sounds way worse than it was. He actually was a really great guy who needed a break and was a really solid dude.
I think he actually ended up back in prison, but he had some really crazy stories. And I was like his manager. I was 18 years old. I was 42 and he's like, and it was just the wild, it was a wild experience. Dude, dude, you kind of grew up fast in that kind of thing, don't you? You learn a lot about like, oh, avoid this. Oh, that's wrong. Oh, I should go over here, right?
It's a great preparation for being an actor. I'll tell you that. Cause like you're walking, like when you're in it, when you're, for the longest time, I was great at auditioning and I couldn't act my way out of a paper bag. Like they'd get on set and they're like, what happened to the actor who came into the thing? I was like, oh, that wasn't an actor. That was a door-to-door salesman.
I walked into a room and I won the role, but I didn't know what the F I was doing. I didn't know how to act, you know what I mean? So starting with those kinds of humble beginnings and really no huge expectations or goals or plans or obviously, you know, things are incredible now, certainly in comparison to that. But even if you had come out with a bunch of ambition and confidence and plans, it still would be incredible right now. So my question is where, where does your current ambition sit? Are you still looking at it through the perspective of the guy living on a beach in Maui?
And if so, you're probably all good and ready to retire at any moment or has, have you morphed into somebody that is like, well, no, I'm just halfway done and I want to go to place X. It's inevitably, I have changed and, you know, my, my, I've grown a lot just because I grew up in a pretty small town and I've just been exposed to a lot more in my life now. So like, I'm, I'm, I'm still ambitious, but I, but I, but I see people similar in like, I guess peers of mine who are prolific actors and stars of movies and brands and icons.
And I, I don't want that, I don't think I want to, I don't want to spend all of my time trying to build like an empire or something because you see some folks that are really driven in that way and that's great for them. But for me, I, I really feel like I want to work to live, you know, and yeah, I get that. You get that from you. I like anytime I see you or either in, you know, on TV or in person at a dinner that we have or whatever, I get that from you. Like you, you, your, your life is very, very full.
Everything is gravy, you know, um, that's the sense I can relate to the, I relate to that too. Yeah. You're good about that, Willie. What are barbecue and shrimp and boiled shrimp, creole, shrimp, this is going to be a nice stitch for the shrimp we're going to make, um, what about, um, what, tell us about the parts of your life that we might not know as much about to the extent you're comfortable. You know, you say you work to live, what, what are some of those things in your life
that work affords you the opportunity to do? And I'm speaking, obviously not about finances, but just your, your personal life, your time, family, stuff like that. Because you do work a lot. Like, you know, you're always working. It's the truth. It's, it's the truth. I have been, I have been working a lot.
I mean, uh, I love, I, I have a farm. I'm really passionate about a farm. I have a ranch and I up in, uh, I've been Washington state and we raise animals and, um, and that's, uh, a big passion of mine. Um, what's your favorite thing to do on the farm? Just to be there, just to, just to be there and to be kind of like, shoot movies, Mads of Uses. Shoot movies.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm doing a reality. I'm doing a reality. Um, but like, do you like, is there a tractor you like to drive? Are you like ride horses? Do you milk cows? We don't have horses.
We have, uh, goats and sheep. I have a, I have a, there's a lake there. I love to fish. I'm a huge bass fisherman. So. Oh yeah. They say that you're, you know, if you want to know where you're, uh, how you're fishing, the heart is, where does your mind go when it wanders?
And for me, I'm just on, I'm, my eyes are closed and I'm just fishing this lake. And I like, it to me, it's like a, it's a 22 acre lake and it's like an aquarium to me. I like, I've put in all these fish and I removed weeds and I'm constantly in the mind thinking about this lake and, and the tight, we just put a new type of, uh, hybrid bass in there called a wiper, which is like a white fishing striper hybrid, which is really extraordinary fish. So obviously you're catching these fish and releasing them back in.
Yeah. Catch and release fish. And I'm going up there for this summer with, uh, after, uh, we have a baby that's doing after the baby's born. I'm taking my nine year old son, Jack, and we're going to go up there and camp for 10 days. It's literally. That's so cool.
It dominates a huge portion of my mind when I'm like, when it's wandering, I'm just, I'm just fishing with Jack up there. And I'm going to show them these 10 movies. I've got like 10 days, 10 movies, and it's going to be like the coming of age summer like, what kind of movies? Yeah. What's on the list? I got the list.
I mean, they're pretty funny movies. Oh, I'll tell you right now. Imagine if there were all Jason Bateman movies that would be so weird off his Christmas party. On my movies. I did your own movies. Don't you get, you're doing it wrong. Um, I got, okay.
Rambo first blood. Sure. Sure. Oh, by the way, that's from that area. This is just you and Jack. We're going to watch these. Yes. Okay.
Great. Uh, Dumb and Dumber. Yep. White Fang. Okay. White Fang. It's like, I think it's based on a Jack London book and I think it may have Ethan Hawke when he was younger.
Yeah. Sure, sure. Yeah. Peabee's Big Adventure. Yes. Oh, yeah. Rudy. Oh, gosh, yeah.
Toy Soldiers. What's that? Oh, yeah. It's like Sean Aston and when they were very young and they like go, their school gets taken over by terrorists and they go crazy and like kill terrorists. Like a Red Dawn type of thing. Yeah. It's like that.
Uh, Red Dawn. Is Red Dawn on the list? Yeah, it's on the list. What about Taps? You got Taps on there? Taps, that's great. I'm adding it to the list. Come on, Chris.
And then we've got Bloodsport and Crouchy Tiger Hidden Dragon and Monty Python and the Holy Grail. Those are the ones on the list. Yes. And we will be right back. All right. Back to the show. I, I, um, um, I was thinking about, um, I really just drifted off there.
Oh, granddad. I can pick it up for you. Just lay down. Lay down. Just pull the microphone down to the floor. There are some cool things that, there's some cool things that Chris, I didn't know, uh, until I read this about you. First of all, I think it's always fascinating for people to hear when you, uh, you audition
for something you didn't get or whatever. We all have our stories, but I didn't know you auditioned for Captain Kirk and the lead in Avatar, both movies. Jesus, you get great auditions. And did you come close to getting them? No, I didn't come close. In fact, it was a real, uh, I know I've, I've, you know, made light of actors feeling rejection or whatever, but I didn't come close.
In fact, I came, it was so not close that I, it was really demoralizing and made me actually truly question my potential or, or what I, or what I should be aiming for as an actor, you know. For which one? For both of those? For both of those. I remember that the role was written like he comes in, it was like maybe the avatar. Were you reading for one of the avatars?
I was reading to place the role in Avatar is one of them and then another one I was reading for Captain Kirk. And then another one I was reading for something that JJ Abrams did, Star Trek, maybe Star Trek. That maybe that was the Captain Kirk, but anyways, I just remember reading that this character description was like, he walks in and he has the it factor. Oh boy. It is just the it factor.
It is guy, you know. And so I was like feeling a little like maybe overweight. I hadn't been taking great care of myself physically. I was like in a relationship where we were kind of drinking a lot and I was just sort of like, you know, I walked in and I, I started sweating immediately and it was a casting assistant and she just looked at me and she just looked down and she just pressed record and like started doing her stuff while I was reading with the other casting assistant. And I saw that there was literally nothing about my, my audition that was compelling
her whatsoever. It was like, it was like, fuck, this is, what am I doing? And I had enough of those in that stretch of a very lean stretch in my career, by the way, that I didn't get hired for a couple of years. It was shortly before parks and rack. And, and then that's when I kind of, I just regaged like, because early on in my early in my twenties, I wasn't, I was in pretty good shape. I was, I was working out a lot.
I was training. I was young and, and I felt like potentially I could, you know, I was mostly getting those roles. The auditions for like douchebag boyfriend, you know, they gotta be like, Hey, my dad's got his escalator so I did the bitch or whatever the line was, you know, it's been two weeks figuring out how to do that line. I never got any, I never read for any douchebag parts. Interesting.
Really? Yeah. It's weird. That is so surprising to me. I know. I know. Really, there's really, really surprising. I've actually never seen anybody more surprised at something than you at that statement.
So anyways, yeah. So I auditioned for those things and I knew in the moment that I, first of all, I wasn't prepared. Like I hadn't done the work that I needed to do physically to be the guy who walks into the room and kind of commands attention. Like, yeah. And so that was when I kind of got Andy and I was like, wait a minute, there's something a little bit maybe more compelling about a clown, you know, that I could play.
I can put this clown, I remember for the first season, I noticed I was self-conscious, like I feel like I'm getting a little chunky. And then I saw the stuff I was doing, I was like, this is actually really funny. And so I told Mike Schur. I was like, I'm going to gain a bunch of weight this summer. He's like, all right, dude. Sounds good. Mike Schur is a showrunner.
Yeah. Mike Schur is a showrunner. And so Andy kind of got fatter and fatter as the seasons went on. By the way, shout out to Mike Schur. Real quick. Yeah. Mike Schur is one of the, one of the all time funniest guys and we knew him back when he was, he used to be a head writer of update and we remember Jayce, we remember how close
we came to that one May where we almost got him to come and write on the second season of Arrested Development. And then he was stolen by Greg Daniels and it was just, there was a moment, he was like, is it going to happen? You're so known. I don't want to blame it on Mitch, but it was Mitch Horwich's fault that he didn't. But thank God, but thank God, because then he went on to the office and then he went on, did Parks and Rec and then he did, you know, The Good Place and Brooklyn Nine-Nine
and all these other great shows with the great game work. Chris, did anybody ever tell, like, I always thought you could be the next Indiana Jones. Did anybody approach you about that? Like why aren't you doing that? Come on, Chris. Well, a lot of what Colin Travarro did with the Owen character that I play in. He's the, Colin's the director of Jurassic World. He's the director of Jurassic World.
And but the Owen character that he like created that he did with me, he bought, a lot of that, you know, obviously, Steven Spielberg did Jurassic Park and so Colin was like creating this ode to the work that Steven had done. And I think borrows a lot of, a lot of, you know, the physicality of like Indiana Jones. And I think that's likely why. And the humor, yeah. Like, you know, like with vests and the humors and the one-liners and the kind of like, even the dynamic between my relationship between my character and Bryce Dallas Howard's character
in the first Jurassic World, it feels a little similar to some of that stuff. So it was kind of an ode in a way to Indiana Jones. So what's the guy Colin like? Is he a nice guy? American guy? Yeah, American guy. Great guy. Really nice guy, super talented and just incredibly dedicated.
I mean, you want, I watch him work in that part of me, the small little flame in the back of my mind is like, you know, maybe I ought to direct is like, oh, I can't, I couldn't do that. I could no way I could do what he does. He's got, he's so thoughtful as a special skill. He's listens to every single person, truly takes in their input, considers it, you know, make sure that everyone feels really good. He has that perfect ability to, you know, not meddle with somebody because actors are
all so different and each so sensitive. You have to actually have a separate skill set of like understanding which technique you're going to use to get what you need from somebody. I was going to say, so Chris, that's why I was asking, is these directors who do that and the ones who are really successful have that ability to take, to wear so many different hats, to listen to so many people, to really collaborate, and it always makes me, when I see them do that and be so good, I always think like, how the fuck does Bateman direct? That's a really strict.
You know what I mean? Because he doesn't possess any of that shit. He's not listening to anybody. Always a lot of time. All he's thinking about, how the fuck can I get out of there and why the fuck are you talking to me? What's the look on his face? I'm trying to shorten the question.
Who the fuck told you to step to me? I'm trying to get the fuck out of here. Oh, you're crazy. Hey, unless you're telling me to tell, coming to tell me that my Tesla is fully charged, I don't want to fucking hear from you. Hey, Chris, before we let you go, I wanted you to tell me a little bit about what we were doing on the show. I want you to tell me about the terminal list, because it's a show coming out on Amazon
that you're starting. Oh my God, you have 85,000 things going on. What is the terminal list about? I'm sure I'm on it. I'm so pumped about it. Can we guess what it's about? Okay. I thought I saw a promo for you where I go, is Pat doing a fucking show, like a limited
series or some shit? So we're in an airport. And you are the person who's in charge of the, so it's the standby, the people who have checked in too late and they could put on a standby list. So you are the guy in the terminal with the list, making people's playing dreams come true. This goes to show you how long ago it was that Jason flew commercial. Yeah. Is that the way it works?
It sounds like a great part. I'm going to tell you what, it's not that. I could see why Amazon would pass on that idea, but okay, don't steal my idea. What is it? So it's based on a New York Times bestselling novel by an author named Jack Carr. Jack Carr is a former Navy SEAL and my buddy Jared, when I did a film called Zero Dark Thirty. Sure you did.
Fantastic. Not a bad film there. That was a good one. And, you know, I play SEAL team six member and in the process of doing that, I got to go down to Coronado and meet the SEALs down there and meet some trained guys who were training the BUDS program down there. That's their training center in Southern California, right? Yeah, right.
That's the BUDS training program. It's like, you know, everyone sees the carrying the logs on the beach and all that tough Navy SEAL training is done down there in Coronado. You don't need to tell me, dude. Yep. I don't need to tell me that. Keep going, tell everybody else. And so I met a guy down there who I ended up kind of shadowing for the character that
I was playing and he to this day is now like my best friend. Oh, that's great. He's a solid as they come, awesome guy. And we've worked together. He was considering going on to team six at that point, but also had always really had a calling to do acting and to be in Hollywood. And so like our paths crossed, we just really had a lot in common. We're both fishermen, we have both like the hunt and get outdoors and I just really love
this guy, you know, just as solid as they come, truly one of my very best friends. And so he knows Jack and he read this book and he goes, hey, check out this book. My friend wrote this book. You might want to make it a movie. And so I read the book and I got, I optioned the book and at the same time, Antoine Foucault, the director Antoine Foucault, he directed Training Day. He directed me in this film, The Magnificent Seven with Denzel Washington. And Antoine was like, I heard that Antoine was also circling this book trying to get
the rights to it. And I was like, hey, I just called them on the side. I was like, dude, instead of us bidding against each other on this book, let me get the rights and I'll just have you direct it. And he said, fantastic. So we did that. And then in reading it, realized that it was probably better suited for a limited series because it's the story of a guy who, you know, the book itself is like a political thriller,
but we made it more of a psychological thriller with a conspiracy element. And so it's like a little bit feels at moments like Jacob's Ladder and has this sort of revenge conspiracy thriller, also this psychological thriller aspect to it. And it's eight episodes on Amazon Prime. It's going to come out July 1st. It's fantastic. I'm so proud of it. It's definitely different than anything I've ever done.
I'm really pumped about it. It's like gnarly. And we hired my friend Jared, who was a producer, got me the book, was a producer on it and plays a role in it. And we hired a whole bunch of people both in front of the camera and behind the camera who were former SEALs and spec ops. So like, we're really nailing down the authenticity of the. That's awesome that you do that.
I love that. You know what I also love? I heard you recently talk about, like you're always inclusive. You're always trying to get everybody, you know, together. I love it. You can feel that from you and you got some guy to be in Jurassic Park, like eating first. Like, what was that story? Something about like some, you had a contest, you didn't even ask the studio.
You're like, Hey, right? Something like that. Well, yeah, this, you know, we, we shot Jurassic World Dominion. We started filming in January when the pandemic hit the States in February. So yeah, you guys were first, right? Weren't you over in England? Yeah, we were, we were first. We got shut down for a few months while they were sort of developing code protocols and
whatever was hunkered down, figuring out, you know, two weeks to flatten the curve or whatever it was at the time. And we went back to work and, you know, our amazing producers on. And Universal, Peter Kramer was, he, you guys drafted up all the sort of back to work protocols for that. Was that, was that our buddy Frank? Was that our buddy Frank Marshall? Yeah.
Frank, Pat Crowley was, yeah, Frank's was on board, but Pat Crowley and Alex Derbyshire were like, I mean, I literally can't imagine how anybody could handle that job, let alone as well as they did, but yeah, they came up with all these protocols and I mean, if there's any industry that's going to be able to take on proceeding through, through the global pandemic, it really is our industry. I think the film and television industry, like we do insane shit. We climb fucking mountains. We build, build, like we do incredible shit.
And it's this sort of, this really hyper vigilant chain of command. We just created a whole, you know, department. It's the COVID department. So everyone's getting tested. Everyone's doing contact tracing. Yeah. All these protocols where people are going to stand and the masks and the shields and all this stuff and people are, you know, enforcing the rules, which was a terrible job for anyone
to have to do to be like, Hey, you're not six feet apart. Like that gets really old by the way, that sounds like a great title of a movie for your father-in-law to do. We should pick contact tracing. Oh my God. Doesn't that sound like a good model movie before we get down to this? I will not. Listen, you put him in an airport with a standby list and nobody's going to the fucking airport
with the standby list. The standby list is not, I hate to say it, but they're right, it's not going to be. It plays overseas. You're off the list. I fucking, but I'd love to watch that. I love that guy. But you got, but you, you had, you had this fake contest or something. Yeah.
We had a fake contest. So, you know, at the time we were trying to raise money for Feeding America. There's this thing called the all in challenge and a whole bunch of people contributed various auction items. It raised $60 million or something like that, $59 million. And our contest item that we raised was an opportunity to be eaten by a dinosaur in Jurassic World. And so everyone entered for 10 bucks, you'd get a chance to enter in this dude named Terry
Thompson from Missouri is, has an amazing death scene in our film. He won the contest and we shot him a green screen. It's so cool. So let me ask you about that. Just as a fan of that, of those movies, when a guy gets snatched up by a dinosaur, pulled out like that classic bit where ripped up off the ground and chew, is, is any portion of that where the person, I'm imagining the person that won this contest got hooked up to a harness and gets snatched up in the air and then they kind of, it becomes digital
at some point. That's typically what you'll do. Yeah. Typically you're going to do something like a full like harness and have a stunt rigging crew pull a person up. Most of the time it's going to be a trained stuntman. So I think I'm not exactly sure what they did with Terry because he was in Missouri and we were in London and they weren't going to, we literally couldn't even fly our own
family members out there. So they set it up the whole green screen and did the whole thing where he was in Missouri. In Missouri. I think they shot him on a green screen just riding a scooter and then maybe did everything and maybe did a scan on him, like one of those body scans and then did everything else. So cool to get, I'm not sure that they put him through the stunt stuff to get people involved and to bring fans in and kind of bring them into what you and Sean and Scotty, you guys did that thing where you got people out of the contest and they come over and eat a plate
of bugles with you and Scotty and who can count how many bugles in the bag and then eat them all. Right. Just work your way through a bag of bugles on Sean's couch. What was the day movement? The big mislead was whoever can guess as many, how many bugles are in the bag, they get to eat them. But the mislead was everybody got a box at the end anyway.
Sure. Which cut into the profits because you guys only raised what a couple hundred dollars I think. Resident. Yeah. We bought more bugles with them. Work your way through a bag of bugles. Chris Pratt, listen, it has been a pleasure.
Thank you for being here. Thank you for wasting your time with us. Sorry, Chris. Pratt. You're the best. This is such a pleasure, you guys. I'm a huge fan of you guys' podcast. I love what you're doing.
You're all so funny. We'll pay it back to you on the golf course. Hey, listen, I also want to say you have earned with all the stuff you've done with the Jurassic World Dominion and now your new series on Amazon, you have earned your 10 days with Jack. I'm so psyched to hear that you guys are going to do that. About the farm. Have the best time.
I want to come up there sometime. That sounds awesome. I love it. You would love it. Anytime. I would love to have you guys up. Anytime. And also...
Yeah, dude. We know we're back. We're back golfing. Chris, thank you. Thanks, Chris. Thank you very much, buddy. It's a pleasure to be here. Keep up to good work.
See you down the road. Great to have you. Bye, pal. Sean, what happens to those bugles? Do they send it to you? Is it their idea? Or you guys... Did you just reach out to a sponsor?
Any sort of chip? Well... It's Cheetos. Chex Mix? Chex Mix? People at Chex Mix never listen. Come back to you. That's what I was trying to say.
Oh, boy. The gang at Chex Mix. But your heart was in the right place. Yeah. Listen, we... Let's do... Sorry, go ahead, Sean. No, no, that's it.
Go ahead. I was going to say that, you know, if anybody's out there from bugles or Chex Mix or Cheez-Its... Cheez-Its. That's what I was thinking of. Cheez-Its. And if you want to have... I actually love Cheez-Its. We do have ourselves.
We can do like a taste test or something like that because these are the things that people really want to talk about. I love Cheez-Its. I love it. I like that. Let's get back to the incredibly unpleasant, nasty Chris Pratt. Just negative. I know.
Just... Oh. I mean, how do we get through that? He's so... My God. So naturally funny. You know what's so funny? When he kind of hit with Jurassic World and Guardians of the Galaxy and he became this huge, you
know, international star, you go, you look at him and you go, yeah, what took Hollywood so long? I mean, look at this guy. The second I saw him, I was like, that's a soup. That's like, like I said, Indiana Jones or like, you know, like he's a leading big blockbuster star. And he wears it well. He really is the same guy that he was 15 years ago.
Yeah. He's so grounded and normal. Great guess, Sean. Nice going. I've always been crazy about him. And yeah, will, I mean, that should have been yours. I just... Oh, no, fuck off.
A better friend. He had talked about it. I saw him like a month ago when we were at Atlanta and we spent the day and I was like, I want to have you on and great. And I called Michael, MGT and everybody knew. But Sean was ahead of you with that. Michael and Bennett and Rob and everybody was conspiring against me again. Arm Yerv.
Robert Arm Yerv is proud to be part of our team. Sean, so now Jason kind of made a joke of it, but what are you, are you taking that shirt out? Today, I did. I did already. I did already. What are we doing? What's dinner?
That's an evening outfit. Dinner's going to be at home. Dinner's going to be at home. Look at it. What is it? Well, I had spaghetti, like I said, and tuna fish for lunch. Jesus. Sorry.
No, you didn't mention the spaghetti the first time. Yeah, I did. Yeah. I had a half a tuna and then like a plate of spaghetti. And then I had a little bit of cheesecake. Wait a second. Together? Yeah.
Do you have tuna fish and spaghetti together? Yeah, you just take a glass of milk and your palate cleanser. Do you have a big race tomorrow or something? Are you trying to get your carbs up or? Yeah, I know. Are you planning, are you going to be fasting? Are you going to do a, are you going on a hunger strike? No, I'm not.
I'm not fasting. I'm fatting. Are your veins too clear? Is it, there's too much blood flow? So, so you're doing this, you're having, you had spaghetti and tuna, how do you top it tonight? Yeah. I got to have a salad.
I got to do something healthy tonight. Cause that was helpless. So what do you think it'll be? So it'll be a wedge with blue cheese. I think it'll probably be a salad. It'll be a salad, um, just like a, like maybe a BLT salad. You mean a salad between bread? No, are you going to, no, I know a BLT salad.
Are you going to go make it or are you going to go, are you going to go pick it up? Yeah, I'm going to go pick it up. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You are? Yeah. I got to eat something. Well, where we can cut this, but we won't, but where we could cut it, where are you going to pick up the salad from Jason?
Your lighting is fucking phenomenal. Like indie film much. So is it, is it, does Chin Chin make a BLT salad? No, um, there's a, there's a restaurant near me that makes a BLT salad. I don't understand. How do they fry his salad? How do they wrap a salad in one of those little dough pinches? They just jump on the letter and they just, they, the same thing they use for the fries
and then they just, the basket, they scoop it up. Oh my God. You guys, I have one word to tell you. Ready? Bye. Is that it? Bye. Smart.
What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart. What? Smart.
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
What? What? What? I'm Rob, I'm Jerv. Smart. What? Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.